apprendre à prendre c'est quelque chose
de banal
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait tous les
jours vous et moi que vous soyez
étudiant vous allez faire vos
présentations vous allez travailler sur
vos projets que vous soyez dans le monde
actif que vous travaillez sur des
projets tous les jours vous allez gagner
ce qu'on appelle de l'expérience
professionnelle bien ce que vous allez
faire c'est apprendre
alors j'ai créé mon entreprise dans le
monde de l'éducation
parce que justement c'est ma passion
j'essaie de montrer en fait aux gens
comment est ce qu'on fait pour apprendre
et je me suis rendu compte en fait dans
mon entourage j'ai énormément
d'entrepreneurs et c'est assez fascinant
comme certains de ces entrepreneurs
je mange souvent avec eux je vais dîner
peut-être une fois par mois avec eux et
à une personne en particulier qui me
fascine énormément cette personne en
fait à chaque fois que je la vois me dit
toujours tu sais quoi
j'ai changé d'idée ce que je fais
maintenant j'ai appris ça et est en fait
c'est assez fascinant parce que cette
personne à chaque fois que je dois me
dit j'ai appris et on se rend compte
qu'en fait c'est une personne qui a une
facilité d'apprentissage est donc
aujourd'hui j'ai pas la prétention de
vous apprendre à apprendre ni même la
science infuse mais j'aimerais vous
donner des outils et vous parler de mon
expérience et c'est ce qui m'a permis
d'avoir eu le courage d'apprendre
alors apprendre ça requiert beaucoup de
composantes dans votre vie est d'accord
vous allez avoir besoin de plusieurs
choses pour pouvoir apprendre pour
pouvoir continuer votre apprentissage
la première chose dont vous avez besoin
c'est d'avoir un objectif
d'accord c'est très dur d'avoir un
objectif très peu de personnes actu en
fait on a un objectif
est-ce que parmi vous dans la salle
pouvait me dire pouvait lever la main et
me dire que vous avez un objectif clair
et précis
un objectif que ce que vous faites tous
les jours c'est quelque chose que vous
allez faire de plus en plus que vous
allez vous vous impliquez dedans et
c'est est ce qu'il ya des gens dans la
salle pas beaucoup beaucoup
pourquoi pourtant pourtant ce que vous
faites tous les jours vous êtes étudiant
vous apprenez tous les jours oui mais la
question c'est de se dire dans quel but
dans quel but est ce qu'on apprend parce
que finalement il a trois types
d'apprentissage et cet apprentissage
lorsqu'on a un objectif on a ce qu'on
appelle de la motivation d'accord on va
être motivé
tout simplement parce que on va suivre
un idéal quelque chose qu'on essaie de
faire et le problème de la société
actuelle c'est que beaucoup de personnes
se retrouvent dans un objectif factice
ou alors n'y pense pas forcément
d'accord ils vont aller au travail ils
vont aller à l'école sans forcément
savoir pourquoi
et puis c'est après en fait c'est après
qu'on va se poser la question mais
pourquoi j'ai fait ça finalement est-ce
que beaucoup d'entre vous se disent
pourquoi est ce que j'ai fait ça souvent
non oui oui effectivement
et donc en fait il ya trois types de
motivation si vous voulez lorsque vous
apprenez vous allez avoir la motivation
en fait qui vient de la passion donc ça
vient de vos valeurs ça vient de l'amour
que vous avez pour faire quelque chose
vous allez avoir la passion parce que
vous aviez d'exceller donc c'est la
passion de la compétition
par exemple comme les sportifs qu'on a
eu juste avant on a envie d'aller
jusqu'au bout on a envie d'être le
meilleur et du coup on va apprendre plus
facilement et on a la motive
sion aussi c'est la plus dangereuse
c'est la motivation en fait par le bâton
on est motivés parce qu'on a peur on va
faire des choses parce qu'on a peur ça
peut arriver dans le monde de
l'entreprise de se dire ah je suis
obligé de faire ça du coup je vais le
faire mais je vais le faire parce que
finalement j'ai peur j'ai peur de me
faire licencier ou peut-être j'ai peur
d'être mal vu de mes autres collègues et
souvent c'est ce qui se passe la plupart
des gens et on a du mal en fait à
réfléchir sur notre vie prendre cinq
minutes et se dire qu'elle est vraiment
mon objectif
ma technique un mois pour définir mon
objectif parce que je me suis dit
pourquoi pas réfléchir en fait à ce qui
s'est passé dans ma vie réfléchir à
comment j'ai pu définir les objectifs et
en fait c'est passer par une seule chose
est ce moyen en fait c'est l'écriture
alors je suis pas un écrivain je suis
pas une personne qui va vous expliquer
comment écrire un roman mais ce que je
fais tous les soirs c'est que je prends
mon carnet ne prenez pas de morceau de
papier parce que vous allez devenir
addict et ça va vous prendre énormément
de de petit-bourg ce papier donc je
prends ce carnet là je prends un stylo
et je note ce qui s'est passé dans ma
journée
alors je note pas tout bien évidemment
ce que je vais noter c'est vraiment les
points importants qu'est ce que j'ai
remarqué
quels sont les petits détails et c'est
ces petits détails en fait qui vous
allez vous rendre compte si vous le
faites vous même que vous passez à côté
de certaines choses et donc moi au début
je me disais c'est débile
pourquoi est ce que je vais écrire sur
un papier qu'est ce que j'ai à écrire
j'ai même rien écrire et les jours
passèrent d'accord j'ai eu jarry n'écrit
pourront pendant la première semaine et
peu après je me suis dit ah
aujourd'hui j'ai lu un article
intéressant une entreprise a créé une
liste de café où on peut travailler il
ya du wifi à new york
quelle idée absolument géniale peut-être
que je pourrai faire exactement la même
chose à londres puis ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'au fur et à mesure je notais
donc je pense être quelqu'un d'un peu
créatif et de me dire à chaque fois à
chaque fois j'ai des idées d'entreprises
mais finalement je
jamais d'accord et je vais le noter et
c'est cette petite obsession qui grandit
en fait au fond de vous parce que tout
simplement ce qui va se passer c'est que
plus vous écrivez et plus vous vous
rendez compte de ce que vous avez
vraiment envie de faire dans votre vie
et même si vous n'agissez pas ce qui va
se passer c'est que vous allez
développer une sorte de mal être
peut-être que ça va faire mal au fond
nous et finalement au bout du compte
vous allez avoir ce déclic
vous allez faire les choses d'accord
vous allez faire ce qu'on appelle vous
allez vous lancer
et c'est la chose la plus importante
lorsque vous reprendre ça l'air de rien
mais ce qui est vraiment important c'est
d'être capable de se lancer pour très
peu de gens ne se lance dans la vie tout
simplement parce que ils ont soit peur
peur de l'échec
c'est pareil pour tout le monde tout le
monde a peur de l'échec ou alors on se
met des obstacles
on se donne des prétextes des excuses et
on se dit ah non à prendre ces mêmes
changer de secteur d'activité c'est pas
pour moi soit je suis trop vieux
soit je suis trop jeune parce que
justement j'ai pas encore les
compétences nécessaires
en fait ces défauts obstacle c'est des
obstacles qu'on s'impose à soi parce que
finalement vous gagnez de l'expérience
dans dix ans je vous revois vous allez
peut-être avoir une famille des enfants
et vous allez avoir des contraintes qui
vont évoluer avec vous donc n'ayez pas
peur de vous lancer dans ce que vous
faites moi pour moi c'était un peu dur
pour me de me lancer la première fois
lorsque je me suis lancé que je me suis
dit j'ai envie de créer mon entreprise
j'adore la technologie je vais apprendre
à coder je vais apprendre à programmer
je me suis dis mais pas ce qu'est ce que
c'est vraiment parce que c'est ce que
c'est vraiment nécessaire
est-ce que j'ai pas j'ai pas vraiment le
temps comment est ce que je vais faire
pour apprendre
c'est ce genre de choses qu'on se pose
et puis je me suis dit alors c'est tout
récemment j'ai regardé une vidéo sur
internet
donc j'imagine que beaucoup d'entre vous
regardent des vidéos sur youtube et j'ai
vu cette personne en fait c'est un
américain sert un speaker qui parle de
la motivation et de tout ce qui va nous
motiver et nous aider à aller plus loin
dans la vie hélas une astuce qui est
assez simple comment se lancer dans les
choses
et cette astuce en fait si vous voulez
c'est de se poser une question simple et
cette question c est si alors est ce que
ça vous est déjà arrivé de vous dire
penser à un moment dans votre vie où
vous vous êtes dit et si j'avais fait ça
autrement je l'aurais fait et je referai
cette décision à nouveau je changerais
cette décision est ce que ça vous est
déjà arrivé de faire ça oui enfin si ça
vous êtes par exemple ceux qui sont en
école de commerce
lorsque vous n'avez pas travaillé pour
rentrer de près par en première année
que vous êtes retrouvés à gm par défaut
est ce que vous a dit et si j'avais plus
travailler j'aurais plus travailler
derrière
j'aurais eu à chaud c'est non eh ben
c'est ce qui se passe dans la vie de
tous les jours posez vous cette question
et si d'accord pensez à bien vous poser
cette question
mais si vous voulez ça ramène quand même
à une contradiction parce que si vous
vous dites
et si le problème c'est que vous allez
avoir deux choix vous avez soit par
exemple continue dans le choix qui n'est
peut-être pas le bon pour vous ou aller
dans la bonne direction
donc pour moi c'est assez abstrait de se
dire ici est la meilleure méthode que
j'ai trouvé c'est de me donner de la
sécurité lorsque j'utilise ce et si par
exemple je me dis et si au bout de six
mois je te garantis que tu réussiras
faire ça est-ce que tu sacrifies des six
mois pour prendre action est à prendre
je pense que la réponse est oui pour
beaucoup d'entre vous on a besoin de
sécurité et c'est normal ensuite pour
apprendre parce que
finalement on a eu l'objectif on a aussi
être capable de se lancer mais lorsqu'on
se lance on se lance ou qu'est-ce qu'on
va apprendre par où commencer
quelle est la bonne route finalement
parce que finalement lorsqu'on commence
à apprendre tout seul on se dit bah je
sais pas vraiment on a beaucoup été
guidés dans notre éducation
on nous a dit pour passer de la
troisième à la seconde il faut connaître
tel type de choses pour pc la seconde à
la première pareil mais après lorsque
vous rentrez dans la vie de tous les
jours et que vous voulez par exemple
progressé dans votre carrière
c'est à vous et à vous de prendre cette
décision c'est à vous de vous lancer et
donc l'idée en fait pour aller dans la
bonne direction c'est d'avoir ce qu'on
appelle un modèle alors qu'est ce qu'un
modèle un modèle c'est un idéal de
personnes qu'on aimerait être ou alors
de carrière qu'on aimerait avoir
et c'est à ce moment là c'est quelqu'un
en fait qu' au sud nous et qu'on va
regarder un peu de haut ça peut être une
personne qui nous inspire ça peut être
une personne qui est dans notre
industrie et qui est très bonne et donc
l'idée c'est que cette personne a déjà
fait nos erreurs dans son apprentissage
donc elle sait ce qu'il faut faire elle
sait les bonnes décisions à prendre
alors ce que je vous invite à faire
c'est vous de vous trouver un modèle
alors beaucoup de personnes font la même
erreur
c'est à dire que lorsqu'on leur parle de
modèle ils vont directement allé voir la
personne qui est tout en haut
alors que c'est la plus grosse erreur à
faire parce que ces personnes qui sont
toutes en hausse et des personnes qui
sont inaccessibles
c'est des personnes avec qui vous allez
même pas pouvoir parler si vous avez
parlé avec un milliardaire qui a déjà
réussi cette personne ait une accessible
pouvait pas y accéder
même si vous pouviez y accéder ce la
réalité de cette personne n'est plus la
même parce que vous en êtes pas au même
point
donc l'idée derrière tout ça c'est de
vous dire je vais avoir un modèle mais
juste une personne qui est juste un peu
ensuite vous d'accord c'est beaucoup
plus accessible c'est des personnes qui
sont très contents de vous aider déjà
être très content parce qu'elle se
sentiront un peu flatté c'est que vous
les approchez que vous leur dites et des
mois et donc c'est ça et puis plus vous
à l'avancé
et plus vous avez besoin de changer de
modèle d'accord ensuite ce que vous
allez avoir besoin de faire lorsque vous
savez où aller et que vous avez définies
justement votre objectif est que vous
vous êtes lancé
vous allez avoir besoin de faire ce
qu'on appelle de la déconstruction
vous allez avoir besoin de déconstruire
en fait l'apprentissage par exemple
quand j'ai quand j'ai appris il ya
programmé
j'ai commencé à apprendre le langage
html
j'ai commencé à apprendre le langage css
le langage javascript rubio noël des
bases de données
apprendre à créer un serveur j'en passe
mais c'est sans fin d'accord même au
delà de ça lorsqu'on sort de la
programmation on va aussi avoir d'autres
composantes donc par exemple si on crée
son entreprise on va voir la
programmation d'un côté donc qui va
consister à créer son produit on va
aussi avoir à connaître du web marketing
ou du marketing on va avoir besoin
d'être bon en vente de connaître la
finance est donc cet apprentissage est
sans fin et si vous voulez lorsque j'ai
appris à programmer j'ai eu cette
logique de me dire que lorsque je veux
créer quelque chose je vais essayer de
tout des composés en petits morceaux
donc par exemple si je vais vous dire
quelque chose peut-être qu'il va pas
parler à tout le monde mais si j'essaie
de construire un système
d'authentification
donc c'est le se connecter sur mon site
internet
ce que je vais faire c'est que je vais
regarder un peu toutes les possibilités
je vais me dire alors pour créer ça
c'est assez long c'est assez c'est assez
dur parce que je vais faire c'est que je
vais tout d'abord mettre en place un
système de gestion des mots de passe
système d'e-mails qui permet de nous
renvoyer mon passage les oublier
énormément de choses comme ça
et donc ça va vous permettre de tout
décomplexifier et de tout construire pas
à pas et c'est ce que vous devez faire
dans votre apprentissage vous devez
prendre quelque chose qui est gros qui
n'atteignaient à bhl et le diviser en
une succession de petites étapes
tout simplement parce que divisés
quelque chose en plusieurs étapes ça va
vous permettre de rester
motivés pourquoi est-ce que vous allez
rester motivé tout simplement parce que
lorsqu'un objectif est trop loin ou trop
vague
on va se disperser on va c'est partir
alors que lorsque on est capable de se
mettre des points de référence des
milestone des tout ce que vous voulez eh
ben on va atteindre petit à petit tous
ses objectifs et l'apprentissage si vous
voulez le succès de l'apprentissage
c'est d'être capable de succéder d'avoir
du succès dans toutes ces différentes
étapes d'accord parce que la progression
si vous voulez dans votre vie même si
vous allez l'homme vous vous rendez
compte
même si vous atteignez pas vos objectifs
mais que vous progressez vous avez ce
sentiment de bien-être de bonheur
d'accord par exemple si vous allez un
truc tout bête
vous allez voir votre patron vous lui
demander une augmentation vous lui
demandez le double et vous dis non c'est
pas possible on n'a pas de budget si
vous le faites vous diront tout ça est
ce qui va se passer ce qui va vous
donner un petit peu même et vous allez
vous sentir heureux parce que tout
simplement parce que vous avez eu un
petit peu et ça ça a était
complémentaire à votre objectif final
est donc déconstruire ce que vous faites
c'est peut-être une des choses les plus
importantes et bien sûr si vous voulez
l'apprentissage c'est quelque chose sans
fin quelque chose que vous allez faire
toute votre vie mais le vrai
apprentissage le succès dans
l'apprentissage c'est l'apprentissage
qui va vous permettre de réaliser vos
rêves
et si dans dix ans je vous revoie ses
possibles 1 contre croiser un jour
j'aimerais que vous soyez capable de me
dire j'ai eu le courage d'apprendre
merci
alors est-ce qu'on peut mettre la
lumière s'il vous plaît c'est que si
vous voulez je vers quelque chose
inhabituelle c'est que j'aimerais bien
prendre à celle fille avec vous d'accord
parce que si vous voulez faire un toc
c'était un de mes rêves c'est un de mes
objectifs et je pense l'avoir atteint
aujourd'hui c'est un pas vers mon
objectif merci à tous